[Musik]
ich möchte mich selbst nie am seidenen
faden ist der neue film von paul thomas
anderson kann nur sagen es ist der
letzte film mit dengel der lose hat er
angekündigt dass er danach aufhört ich
würde aber sagen es ist der erste film
in dem wiki krebs eine hauptrolle hat
und diesen namen müssen wir uns merken
ist eine junge darstellerin aus
luxemburg die mit einer unglaublichen
courage gegen diese schauspiel legende
zu der sich ja selber auch gemacht hat
und wir alle dazu ihn auch gemacht haben
gegen diese legende an spielt wird koch
ist der name der figur level des spiels
ein schneider als ich ein kleiner junge
war kann ich dem futter von
kleidungsstücken zu verstecken
ich wusste es geht in diesem film und
jedes geschichte dieses mannes mit der
frau die die vicky krieps spielt würden
sie mir zu andersen am anderen
lebensgefühls ist doch sehr
ungleichgewicht ich weise sie kommen vom
land er kommt aus der stadt sie kommt
aus einem osteuropäischen land oder auch
sogar aus deutschland leicht also man
weiß es nicht so genau jedenfalls ein
bisschen akzent das ist flämische
klöppel spitze aus dem späten 17
jahrhundert und er ist eben der lebemann
und der der bescheid weiß wie es läuft
jetzt sie zu
er entwirft also kleider für sie ist
erst mal sein perfektes modell dann
beginnt sie ihn zu inspirieren wird zu
seiner muse und dann erst zu seiner
geliebten wie das weitergeht jetzt gar
nicht alles alles erzählen aber sie
erweist sich so wie eben auch vicky
krieps sich als ebenbürtig dem so
wahnsinnig studierten denn hier denn los
erweist mit ihrer eigentlich ganz
natürlich wirkenden technik des
schauspiels so ist auch alma dem weinort
eigentlich gewachsen
machen sie schon es hatte längst
erledigt und ganz verstehen
angesichts dessen dass denke das klingt
ziemlich glaubhaft angekündigt hat dass
dies sein letzter film ist würde ich
jedem empfehlen sich anzugucken auch um
zu sehen wie dieses so gefeierte märkte
eigentlich ein schauspieler kleinkrieg
so ein bisschen der us- ist so kann so
unglaublich elegant sein und meine
lieblingsrolle mit ihm es nach wie vor
in dem in dem letzten mohikaner von
michael mann für mich auch nach wie vor
der beste film in dem ihr gespielt hat
in diesem film war ja auch schon
methoden schauspieler aber man spürte
noch dass er diese lust die er an sich
selber und an seinem eigenen spiel und
an seiner eigenen attraktivität
natürlich attraktive hat das spürte man
in dem in dem letzten mohikaner
und hier spürt man es gar nicht obwohl
wir immer noch fantastisch aussieht
obwohl er immer noch mit viel mehr noch
dieser große schauspieler ist und meine
art des gipfels macht ihm gar keinen
spaß wenn ich sehr bedauerlich
vielleicht hast du keinen geschmack
vielleicht mag ich meinen eigenen ja da
noch neuen ärger zu bekommen
vielleicht will ich erst los es steckt
so ein bisschen hitchcock drin ist
stecken unbedingt chabrol drin und ich
hätte mir gewünscht da wir um wie noch
mehr passiert in diese richtung so ist
das alles doch sehr gepflegt sie
geblieben und man wünscht sich da so ein
bisschen leben in die bude kommen aber
das passiert eben nur sehr punktuell und
ich habe das gefühl dass sein film ist
sehr sehr stark über die ausstattung
erdacht worden ist und über das kostüm
natürlich und eben noch war eine rolle
für daniel day-lewis bei der ich
allerdings das gefühl habe es ist
eigentlich da meine finger über diesen
mann zu spielen
für mich ist es einfach zu manieriert
kontrolliert aber es insgesamt ich bin
sicher dass ich für die ehrlich
bestimmten ich bin ein eingefleischter
junggeselle
ich bin unverbesserlich und wenn die
vicky krieps mich wäre hätte ich das
gefühl dass der film wie vor auf der
leinwand eigentlich verändert bevor er
überhaupt bei mir angekommen
es kommt mir so vor als wäre ich lange
auf der suche nach dem wesen
[Musik]
du hast mich gefunden
egal was du tust tu es vorsichtig
[Musik]